okay so the topic of today's video will
be cellular immunity versus humoral
immunity so let's go ahead and get
started so as we get started I first
want to focus on cellular immunity now
one of the main points the major points
of focus is that during cellular
immunity T cells are going to be created
that will ultimately destroy infected
cells of your own body
well how does this process of cellular
immunity work more number one a person
needs to be exposed to a pathogen and so
here are some viruses that have just
entered your body pretend notice on the
outside are some lumps that are called
antigens and these are proteins that are
found on the outside of cells and
viruses and all cells and viruses have
them they're lumps of protein and they
help to identify and mark cells that
belong to us versus cells that are
foreign and so what happens is a virus
or a bacteria in this case in my
animation it'll be a virus a virus is
infecting this particular body cell and
now that the cells infected as you might
know viruses will hijack and take over
the cell and turn the cell into a virus
making Factory and as it does that as
the cell is being basically tricked into
making new viruses what happens is some
proteins of the pathogen of the virus of
the bacteria will actually be collected
and displayed on the outside of the cell
membrane of this protective particular
infected cell of your body here that's
gonna be important important step later
on when we get to you know destroying
this particular pathogen so now you
notice that there are other pathogens
that are inside this person's body well
along comes a white blood cell phagocyte
which will devour and swallow up and
engulf this pathogen through the act of
phagocytosis and so here our Fager site
has just engulfed and swallowed the
pathogen now what happens next I think
is kind of interesting
you know the analogy I like to make kind
of takes us back to medieval times and
in medieval times prisoners may have
been executed and their bodies may have
been cut into pieces and body parts
would be then displayed at various parts
of the kingdom as a reminder of what
happens to those who try to lead a
rebellion against the king now that's a
little analogy for what happens next so
what happens next is our Faga site will
destroy the pathogen but then present on
the surface of itself it'll present
antigens of the now destroyed pathogen
so this is now known as a antigen
displaying phagocyte so now that the
phagocyte is displaying antigens what
happens is a t-cell a type of white
blood cell called a t-cell an
inactivated t-cell will come along and
bind to the antigen displaying Faga site
now t-cells don't actually look like the
letter T I've kind of just drawn it that
way to help help us kind of keep track
of what everything is
but this inactivated T cell is gonna be
really important in getting rid of the
pathogen that's you know getting a sick
so now that the T cell has binded to the
antigen display in phagocyte the antigen
display and Faga site will release
proteins that will be picked up by this
in activated T cells and the proteins
will actually activate the T cell the T
cell once activated will be stimulated
to multiply and divide and replicate
into a couple categories one category
being memory T cells
so as my activated T cell now begins a
multiply notice how its multiplying into
memory T cells now these memory T cells
are really important in fighting the
pathogen should you encounter it later
on at some other time in your life you
will have these memory cells memory T
cells built up in reserve and they'll
spring into action should you ever
encounter this pathogen again but let's
get rid of the memory T cells and let's
just focus on
carrying this current infection so the
other category that's going to be
created now that the memory T t-cells
have been created are going to be the
active T cells so not only will the T
cell divide into memory T cells but that
T cell will divide into active or plasma
T cells so again the antigen presenting
Vega site has released proteins that
will stimulate the T cell to multiply
and now we have basically an army of
these T cells to not only fight the
pathogen should it encounter later on in
your life with the memory T cells but
also it now has created an army to fight
the current infection and that's really
what the active T cells are the plasma T
cells do they fight the current
infection so what they're gonna do is
they're gonna one of them is gonna bind
to this infected body cell remember the
infected body cell is displaying
antigens of the virus as well and so the
activated t cell will recognize the
pathogens antigens as being foreign into
the t cell well attached to the infected
body cell and the t cell the active T
cell will begin to release proteins and
enzymes that will ultimately destroy
this infected body cells this type of T
cell by the way is called a cytotoxic T
cell it kills this particular cell of
your body and over time notice how the
cell is destroyed and then healthy
neighboring cells will multiply through
mitosis and kind of reoccupy that space
okay so that was cellular immunity now I
want to shift focus to humoral immunity
now the main major point I want you to
know with humoral immunity is that
during humoral immunity b-cells are
created that are gonna produce a whole
bunch of antibodies with the purpose of
fighting off whatever the pathogen is so
first of all the person is going to be
exposed to a path
the gin and here are some pathogens that
have just entered this person's perhaps
their bloodstream and next what happens
is b-cells will already have membrane
bound antibodies in them so here comes a
b-cell and again no it does not look
like the letter B I've kind of just done
that so we can kind of keep track what
everything is
but notice how there are these Y shaped
structures poking out of the B cell
these are the membrane bound antibodies
and the B cell has these membrane bound
antibodies that will attach itself to
the matching antigen of the virus or the
bacteria or the pathogen whatever is
foreign and what happens next is the B
cell will engulf and swallow up and
destroy and break down the pathogen
through doing the act of phagocytosis
and just like we saw a moment ago this
kind of reminds me of medieval times
where again the body parts of victims
are are displayed around the kingdom as
a reminder not to rebel against the king
so cells of the immune system kind of go
medieval and break down and display the
body parts of the pathogen and so the
antigens of the pathogen are going to be
displayed on the surface of this
particular B cell right here now this is
now called an antigen presenting B cell
and so what happens next is a t-cell
known as a helper T a helper T cell or
bind to this antigen presenting B cell
now there's a reason it's called a
helper T cell it's going to help
activate this particular B cell and it
does so by releasing various proteins so
the helper T cell will release these
proteins which will activate this
antigen presenting B cell and now that
the antigen presenting B cell has been
activated the B cell will be stimulated
to multiply and divide
to basically create an army of itself
and when it multiplies and divides it'll
mult multiply and divide into a couple
categories of b-cells number one being
the memory b-cells and as we said a
moment ago the memory b-cells are
created and are used in case you ever
encounter the pathogen at a future time
in your life you will have this immune
system army of b-cells already built up
in reserve to fight the pathogen so
let's remove the b-cells and let's focus
on our current infection and so as the
b-cell has now been activated and
multiplies it will also produce active
b-cells the army of b-cells that will
fight this current infection and so what
happens is the b-cells are basically
turned into a factory to make antibodies
and notice how inside of the b-cell are
these Y shaped structures these are the
antibodies the antibodies are produced
and released into the blood plasma into
the bloodstream and so now that your
blood has antibodies flowing through it
well what happens next well if we just
focus on the antibodies that have been
released from the b-cells the antibodies
are now flowing through the blood well
how do the antibodies actually destroy
the pathogen well there's a variety of
ways one what they do is they will
simply attach themselves to the antigens
of the pathogen and by doing so it just
interferes with the pathogens ability to
infect other cells
another way that antibodies are helpful
antibodies will actually kind of like a
little handcuff attach itself to an
antigen of a pathogen and then kind of
draw and cause a couple of them to clump
together like little handcuffs and as
this happens there are other antibodies
will attach themselves to the pathogens
to this big clump of pathogens and this
really tags the pathogen as being a
foreign invader and now that the
of viruses or bacteria now that the
clump of pathogens has been tagged along
comes a Vegas ID a white blood cell
which will swallow up the the big mass
of viruses and bacteria and then are
destroyed by by the phagocyte after it
swallows up and and is breaks them down
and so as time passes the current
infection is is defeated by the cells of
your immune system and so there you have
it there is I hope a nice side-by-side
comparison of humoral vs. cellular
immunity so if you're in my biology
class you know try this practice quiz
pause the video answer them on a
separate sheet of paper and bring me
your answers I'd love to check them for
accuracy so I hope you found this video
helpful thanks for watching